hey youtubers it's Charlie so the big
news is is that Hulk is going to be a
part of thor ragnarok it started that as
a little bit of a rumor then it started
to be confirmed by the trades so if you
weren't sure it is definitely a thing
now that doesn't necessarily mean
they're doing any kind of Planet Hulk
storyline remember Universal still has
the distribution rights for solo hulk
films so Marvel Disney not gonna release
any solo hook films till they get 100%
of the profit participation that's like
a whole other story is just the Disney
is like the largest distributor of
movies in the world so they don't like
to give money to other people if they
don't have to and that naturally they
don't have to do it in the case of Hulk
so they're just gonna wait it out Mark
Ruffalo though is getting older by the
day and they said that there was so much
stuff going on and Captain America Civil
War that he just didn't make final cut
they they had to cut him out of the film
so naturally you can't have Hulk ride
the bench for the entirety of phase 3 so
thor ragnarok just makes sense
just remember this scene from the first
Avengers film think about what they can
do with Hulk on a planet full of
Asgardians suddenly the fact that they
can heal so fast makes so much sense now
it's gonna be like whack-a-mole with
Thor's hammer just like pounding them
into the ground one at a time it's been
a little while since I made a Thor video
but what they've been saying about
Ragnarok is is that it's closer to Jack
Kirby's Ragnarok than the Civil War
clone there's been a lot of confusion
about that the minute that they
announced it as it film people were like
are they gonna clone Thor is this is
this gonna be from Civil War cuz they're
doing civil war the movies during civil
war Thor's gonna be off planet dealing
with what's going on in Asgard you know
dealing with the visions that he had
during Avengers age of Ultron about the
Infinity stones in his absence it's
totally possible that they could try to
replicate his power somehow not
expecting any kind of cloning though
that would be like creating another
version of Ultron it'd be like recycling
that storyline where Tony Stark
accidentally creates a monster so no
Civil War Ragnarok clone the story
behind Jack Kirby's Ragnarok is actually
really interesting
obviously the movies are gonna change a
whole bunch of stuff they always do it
just to make a little bit simpler a
little bit more linear but what happened
during Jack Kirby's Ragnarok is is that
his original intention was was to bring
in the new gods and have them replace
the Asgardians in Marvel Comics pantheon
of characters like the place that the
Asgardians like
Odin that they held in the comics would
become the new gods that ended up
showing up at DC Comics
it's just that Jack Kirby's contract
like he signed a contract with DC when
this is all going on news is like a
small feud with Marvel so he's like fine
I'll take the new guys to DC and we'll
do him over there so Ragnarok was kind
of like this housecleaning event for
Marvel they wanted to kill off a bunch
of the Asgardian characters they didn't
like in the ones that did come back just
came back that much more hardcore
they they do it almost every single year
with the big event just like they're
doing with battleworld right now
battleworld is kind of like a
transdimensional version of Ragnarok but
the big thing during that is that Thor
died and was reborn some of the comic
book storylines I'm going to talk about
might be spoilery so just potential
spoilers for Marvel's civil war in the
comics not not the movies just the
comics there's a lot of talk about
Captain America maybe dying
Bucky taking the mantle there have been
so many times that different characters
have died and other characters have
taken their mantle in the comics then
it's really hard to predict what Marvel
is gonna do I think a lot of it just
depends on which actors reassign their
contracts now if you remember Kevin
Feige just took Marvel Studios to like
its own separate place at Disney they
essentially have autonomy now from the
rest of Marvel's operation Kevin Feige
has like his own protective bubble to
make really awesome movies that means
that he can treat his stars a lot nicer
so they don't all bolt for the door the
minute their contracts are up so they
can earn more money at a different
studio doing other movies I mean at some
point eventually one of these core
Avengers is gonna say okay I'm good I've
made like 10 billion Avengers movies I
don't need to do this anymore please
kill me off and fill my spot with
another character well that's kind of
what phase 3 is about just like opening
up the roster to new characters but just
jumping back to thor ragnarok what the
hell is going on in this movie is in
loki has been masquerading as Odin using
Asgard as his own personal base of
operations probably going to have to pay
the piper
as an Thanos who's probably going to
come and try and raid Odin's weapons
vault and then you have other big
characters like big cosmic villains like
fire Lords Serdar way way back in the
continuity Odin trapped Fire Lord
Serdar with the help of his two brothers
that ended up dying but in the course of
events he was infused with their life
force energy and that became the
odinforce if you want to read like
some of those really old classic Thor
stories most of it is on Marvel
unlimited is really cool if you have a
couple weekends to burn there's just
there's a lot of it but essentially
think of Hulk's presence in Thor
Ragnarok is like Robert Downey jr.
presents in Captain America Civil War
it's still gonna be a Thor movie
Hulk is just gonna be a very important
part of it it's just that in Captain
America even though Iron Man Robert
Downey jr. major actor he is really like
a smaller part of the film than Captain
America is it's still a Captain America
film but you guys can let me know like
what do you want to see Hulk do with
Thor in this movie obviously he's a good
character so he's gonna be fighting with
Thor against low Qian you know whoever
else is causing trouble in Asgard
hopefully Fire Lord sir I'm hoping for
like a mega cosmic villain that would be
awesome
just expect them to deliver on the
promise of the title Ragnarok just
complete destruction and just in case
there's any confusion about what
happened to Hulk at the end of Avengers
age of Ultron really think they left it
ambiguous so that they could do whatever
they want to with them like if something
like this happened they could be like oh
he went to space or if they didn't want
him to go into space they could be like
oh it went to the bottom of the ocean
and he just bailed out that's the thing
about Kevin Feige and Marvel was like
they have a plan for every single
character for every single contingency
so like if an actor bails on a contract
or if they become available all of a
sudden they just have multiple ideas
four character arcs depending on who's
around and what the circumstances are
whenever they're actually making these
films it's actually pretty clever but
this is like a billion-dollar industry
so of course they're gonna have
contingency plans so until you hear
otherwise
Hulk is still on planet Earth they will
probably address what's going on with
him during Captain America's Civil War
they might just mention it but we
probably won't see him if we get really
lucky they might totally pull in
illuminati and shoot him into space but
the problem is is that you would have to
establish why they would shoot him into
space and in the comics it was because
he freaked out like they would have done
it after this johannesburg sequence when
he went apeshit on everybody and
destroyed the city just more changes
from the comic books that marvel's got
to deal with in the movies they usually
do a pretty good job of explaining
things so i'm not super worried but i
just had a chance to see loki in crimson
peak which is a totally badass movie so
I'll probably do a review for that after
Doctor Who on Saturday be sure to
subscribe to get that Tom Hiddleston is
awesome in it Jessica Chastain though
she
queen she is the best part of that movie
I still have a Walking Dead Q&A to do so
I'll try get that up next and then there
should be Doctor Who maybe a couple
trailer videos in there somewhere
there's just like a lot of really
awesome footage for everything that's
coming right now it's like the best time
of year so while you guys wait for all
the rest of that stuff to post click
here to watch the daredevil season 2
trailer again watch it like 10 more
times it's gonna be so awesome Punisher
is gonna kick so much ass and you can
click here to learn all about Fox and
Marvel coming to an arrangement to do
two new TV shows based on x-men
properties
thank you so much for watching everybody
else at five I'll see you guys tonight
you